[Musique]
les on voudrait que son herbe soit aussi
verte que celle de son voisin
il contacte une entreprise de traitement
de pelouse on y offre un traitement en
quatre étapes que l'on accepte sans
écouter les explications du préposé au
sujet de son contrat erreur et quand il
le reçoit quelques jours plus tard il le
range dans un tiroir sans le lire
deuxième erreur à la fin de l'été
l'herbe est toujours plus verte chez le
voisin que chez les hommes il se dit
qu'il ne rappellera pas cette entreprise
pourtant au printemps suivant elle
revient traiter sa pelouse mais on est
en colère mais ils ne devraient
s'entendre qu'elle lui même s'il avait
bien écouter deux préposés de
l'entreprise la saison dernière et s'il
avait vu son contrat il aurait su qu'il
contenait une clause de renouvellement
automatique et il aurait pu à ce moment
là la refuser le fin mot de l'histoire
une entreprise de traitement de pelouse
qui nous en informe clairement peut
inclure une clause de renouvellement
automatique dans son contrat alors coupé
lui l'herbe sous le pied a refusé